The first wave of coffee started with companies...
...like Folgers, Maxwell House and Nestle.
They took coffee out of the primordial ooze as it were...
...and into every office and home in America.
They brought us things like vacuum packaging, insta-coffee,...
...and catchy slogans like, "The best part of waking up."
Their coffee was known for being relatively bitter, bland and weak-tasting.
Second wave coffee began in direct response to this lack of quality.
Places like Peet's and Starbucks came up with new ways ...
...to distribute a fresher, higher-quality product.
They popularized things like espressos and lattes and baristas,...
...and they educated consumers about where their beans came from...
...and how they're roasted.
When second wave brands made their way into supermarkets...
...and unto retail shelves, this paved the way for third wave coffee.
Companies like Stumptown and Intelligentsia...
...peg their quality to their unique retail experience.
The place and the proprietors became a bigger part of the story,...
...almost as important, some would say, as the brew itself.
Price versus Quality.
Will mainline customers,...
...the type of people who buy their coffee at the supermarket,...
...accept the higher premiums and promised quality from third wave roasters,...
...or will they just continue buying the more cost-conscious...
...and approachable second wave?